s'il te plaît c'est l'anniversaire de la
mort de ma mère je veux juste me changer
les idées
[Musique]
je vais le faire
[Applaudissements]
tu restes plus de 90 secondes c'est bien
clair il arrive quoi après 90 secondes
ils vont vouloir rester
allume la chandelle pour ouvrir la porte
est à la pour la fermer
serre la main
et dit
parle-moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
parle-moi
ça faisait quoi de serrer la main
c'était incroyable je pouvais voir et
sentir tout ce qu'il y a de l'autre côté
avec ma mère était là elle essayait de
me parler maman
je suis là
je vois encore des choses qu'est-ce que
tu veux dire tu vois des choses
et si on avait ouvert la porte mais
qu'on ne l'avait pas fermé
oh mon Dieu ils nous ont suivi
je te laisse entrer
je serais trop pas
il t'aime beaucoup
[Musique]